president biden last week
had an interesting well interesting
admission
i guess we could say and here it is
let's listen
if we fail to act there will be a wave
of evictions and foreclosures in the
coming months
as this pandemic grazes on because
there's nothing we can do to change the
trajectory of the pandemic
in the next several months there's
nothing we can do
to change the trajectory of the pandemic
in the next several months that's what
he just said
you know obviously if we had if we got a
media interested in the actual news
this would be like headline news
everywhere
this is a stunning thing for him to say
considering
what his new administration is in the
process of doing like for example
a 100 day mask mandate
everyone wear the mask for 100 days even
though people have already been wearing
a mask for 100 days more than that
um so why are we doing that
and as far as i know this question has
not been asked by anybody in the media
but it's like okay well if we can't
change a trajectory
um which by the way i'm not necessarily
i'm not saying i disagree with that
actually but if we can't change the
trajectory
then why are we wearing the mask what is
the point of it exactly if it's not to
change the trajectory i thought that was
the entire point
it's not the point then what are we
doing it for meanwhile a local reporter
in california
uh madario's bab is is her name
she has this this is what she reports on
twitter she says i've obtained an email
from the california restaurant
association that says gavin newsom
will be lifting the stay-at-home order
for all regions across the state
tomorrow
um and she continues i'm not sure if
this means the region will fall back
into the tier system but no matter what
it would mean less restrictions the cra
says it was informed of the lift today
by newsome administration but the formal
announcement won't be until tomorrow so
the formal announcement will come today
or has already come i don't know
but this is just another
strange coincidence isn't it like as
soon as biden gets into office he says
well there's nothing we can do to change
the trajectory of the virus
didn't say that before and now you have
california they're lifting those state
home restrictions
opening up the restaurants and we we've
seen this really strange coincidence
in uh in states and regions across the
country
and the thing that makes it even more
coincidental i know this is all because
i don't want to get into conspiracy
theorists
theories right i'll be is if you connect
too many dots you're automatically a
conspiracy theorist you know so
that you don't want to be that so i'll
just say it's a it's a
weird coincidence that not only do we
have
these areas opening up as soon as biden
is inaugurated president
the other strange thing is that all the
areas doing this are run by democrats
but who could possibly draw conclusions
no don't be a conspiracy theorist
don't do that it's just it's a
coincidence you know coincidental things
happen
that's all it is listen hit that
subscribe button
right now do it right now i thank you
for your compliance
it is somewhat appreciated